الغرب هو منذ بدايه الحرب الروسيه على
اوكرانيا لم يكف عن فرض العقوبه عليها
وعلى اقتصادها لكن فعاليه في هذه العقوبه
يبدو انها خيبت امال الغرب والدليل
التوقعات الصادره عن صندوق النقد الدولي
الذي كشف ان الانتاج الروسي يتوسع بنسبه
0.3 هذا العام واثنين فاصل واحد بالمئه
العام المقبل في تحدي للتنبؤات السابقه
متحدثون من الصندوق قال انه عند مستوى
الحد الاقصى الحالي اسعد النفق
لا يتوقع ان تتاثر احجام صادرات النفط
الخام الروسي بشكل كبير مع استمرار اعاده
توجيه التجاره الروسيه من الدول التي تفرض
عقوبات الى تلك التي لا تفرد ذلك تقرير
لصحيفه الامريكيه كشف ان روسيا تتحايل على
العقوبات الدوليه من خلال استيراد ما
تحتاجه من بضائع عبر ارمينيا وتركيا
والصين وبلاسيا وكذاخستان